FIRST RESPONDERS AND GARY SINISE
JOINS ME NOW.
THAT IS HIM PLAYING AND SINGING
WITH THE LIEUTENANT DAN BAND
THERE.
LET ME JUST ASK YOU THIS IN
DIFFICULT TIMES WHERE OUR GREAT
NATIONAL HOLIDAY HAS APPARENTLY
BECOME CONTROVERSIAL, YOU CAN'T
SING GOD BLESS THE USA AND FAKE
IT, CAN YOU?
YOU'VE GOT TO MEAN IT WHEN YOU
DO THAT SONG.
>> WE DO DO THAT SONG.
IT'S GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
WE HAVE DONE THAT SONG IN MY
BAND FOR ABOUT 18 YEARS NOW AT
THE END OF OUR SHOW, IT ALWAYS
CLOSES OUR SHOW, WHO WROTE GREAT
PATRIOTIC ANTHEM TO THE
UNITED STATES AND IT ALWAYS
PLAYS WELL WITH OUR AUDIENCE.
THEY KNOW THE SONG, THEY SING
ALONG WITH IT AND MOST OF OUR
AUDIENCE ARE MILITARY VETERANS,
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO PLAY
HUNDREDS OF CONCERTS FOR THEM
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND THAT IS
ALWAYS A BIG TREAT AT THE END OF
OUR SHOW.
>> Mark: I CAN'T THINK OF ANY
OTHER CHARACTER FROM A MOVIE
THAT BECAME A BAND, THERE IS NO
MARY POPPINS BAND, BUT THERE IS
A LIEUTENANT DAN BAND AND
SOMEHOW I TAKE IT PRESUMABLY BY
ACCIDENT, A CHARACTER YOU PLAYED
IN A MOVIE CONNECTED WITH
MILLIONS OF REAL VETERANS HAS
SOMEHOW GETTING TO THE HEART OF
WHAT IT IS TO SERVE AND TO
SUFFER IN A WAR THAT EDDINS
AMBIGUOUSLY OR ENDS IN DEFEAT
AND YET THERE IS STILL NOBILITY
AND GLORY AND HAVING SERVED YOUR
COUNTRY.
>> A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, I
WROTE A BOOK CALLED GRATEFUL
AMERICAN, A JOURNEY FROM SELF TO
SERVICE IN THE CRACKS HOW I GOT
INTO THIS WITH OUR MILITARY AND
IT STARTS WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
AND MY FAMILY, WORLD WAR I,
WORLD WAR II, KOREA ERA,
VIETNAM, A LOT OF VETERANS IN MY
FAMILY.
I ENDED UP PLAYING A VIETNAM
VETERAN AND FORREST GUMP AND AT
THAT TIME, DONE VERY LITTLE.
HAVEN'T WORKED IN A MOVIE OR
TELEVISION BUSINESS FOR VERY
LONG HAD ALL WHEN I STARTED
GOING OUT AND VISITING TROOPS
AROUND THE WORLD AND GOING TO
HOSPITALS, MOST OF THEM DIDN'T
KNOW WHO I WAS BUT THEY KNEW
LIEUTENANT DAN.
THEY KNEW MY FACE FROM THE MOVIE
SO WHEN I STARTED TAKING THE
BAND WITH ME ON THESE TWO WORDS,
I SAID THEY WILL AT LEAST KNOW
THE GUY WHO PLAYED THE CHARACTER
IS COMING TO SEE THEM AND AS I
SAID SINCE THEN, WE PLAYED
HUNDREDS OF CONCERTS, THE BAND
IS A PROGRAM OF MY FOUNDATION,
SO MUCH LIKE WHEN YOU SUPPORT
THE USO ENTERTAINMENT, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DO IS WE SEND
THE BAND OUT AND YOU CAN HELP US
DO THAT.
>> Mark: LET ME JUST ASK YOU
FINALLY THESE ARE WEIRD TIMES
WHEN A NATIONAL HOLIDAY BECOMES
CONTROVERSIAL, YOU PLAYED A LOT
ON JULY 4TH, PLAYED A LOT ON
MEMORIAL DAY, WHAT DOES
INDEPENDENCE DAY MEAN TO YOU
PERSONALLY?
>> HARDLY CONTROVERSIAL TO ME.
IT'S ABOUT FREEDOM AND HAVING
GONE TO PLACES AROUND THE WORLD,
THE WAR ZONES OF AFGHANISTAN,
IRAQ, PLACES LIKE THAT WHERE
THEY DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT FREEDOM IS, I'VE STOOD ON
THE BORDER BETWEEN NORTH AND
SOUTH KOREA SEVERAL TIMES AND
THEY ARE FREE IN THE SOUTH AND
ENSLAVED IN THE NORTH.
YOU VALUE YOUR FREEDOM THAT MUCH
MORE IN YOU VALUE THE PEOPLE
THAT PROVIDED FOR YOU AND KNOWS
THE MEN AND THE WOMEN OF THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY, THAT'S
WHY I STARTED MY FOUNDATION AND
I WANT TO SUPPORT THEM IN EVERY
WAY I CAN BECAUSE FREEDOM IS
PRECIOUS AND IT HAS TO BE FOUGHT
FOR AND HAS TO BE PROTECTED.
INDEPENDENCE HAS TO BE FOUGHT
FOR AND PROTECTED AND FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE WILLING
TO DO THAT, I JUST WANT TO HELP
THEM OUT.
>> Mark: GOD BLESS YOU, GARY
AND GOD BLESS THE USA.
YOU'VE DONE GREAT WORK FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS AND I'M SURE
THERE ARE MOMENTS WHERE YOU'D
MUCH RATHER BE ON A SOUND STAGE
OR IN A THEATER, BUT YOU DO THIS
WORK, YOU ARE A GREAT ACTOR AND
A GREAT PATRIOT AND THAT
COMBINATION DOESN'T ALWAYS GO
TOGETHER AS OFTEN AS IT SHOUL